Thai voters heading into the polling
Booth early on Sunday morning it's an
election that some say could be the most
important in decades
as he registered his vote the current
prime minister urged ties to do their
Democratic Duty
I would like to invite people all over
the country all ages and gender who are
eligible to cast their vote I want as
many people as they can to come out the
prime ministerial candidate from the
main opposition party per Thai looked
calm as she came to vote but was she
feeling optimistic yes of course I
a very good mood actually so yes I'm
excited but as she cast her ballot
she'll be very aware that election
results here are rarely simple her party
is already under investigation by the
election commission I don't have any
concern I just um I'm I'm just cheering
for for Thailand to for the people to
just come out and you know use their
rights that's all I wanted for now
the deciding factor could be moved
forward whose party leader was also
hoping for a high turnout their message
of Reform could take more support from
the military-backed parties or split the
opposition vote but everyone voting was
Keen that the process went smoothly I
want to say the politician who win the
world themselves and think of the people
first and foremost but the most
important thing is to have Harmony the
most important thing is that we bring
the new changes voting is now drawing to
a close and the election officials are
starting to prepare for the count that
should take about four or five hours
before we get some kind of unofficial
numbers many people are hoping gives a
clear and definitive result
election officials preparing the sheets
on which the votes will be recorded but
now the complicated part deciding who is
one Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok